>>Kirsten: Throughout the next month,
you're going to practice one paragraph.
>>Dr Cantor: Motivation
has a great deal to do
with the belief that
we can be successful.
So what does a grade do to motivation?
It can shut it down pretty quickly,
especially when children
are learning something new.
>>Kirsten: Okay, so we're
going to take five minutes
to workshop and organize our writing.
I'm not going to grade anything.
>>Kirsten: When a grade is
issued, a decision has been made.
The grade becomes definitive.
So a lot of the teachers at King
Middle School use delayed grading.
If you were teaching someone to
swim, you might not throw them
in the deep end and have them swim.
You would start in the shallow end
and you would practice
and practice and practice.
It is a great way to
just give them fluency
and comfort with the writing process.
>>Kirsten: I am not assessing
your spelling, capitalization,
grammar or punctuation at this point.
I'm waiting until the end of the unit.
>>Kirsten: I'll say, "I'm
just worried about your mind,
heart and your gut. Put
it on the paper."
I can then get to the thinking
and the ideas and the details
that they're trying to
practice using in their writing.
>>Masoumeh: It's real and true
that some people die in Syria.
>>Masoumeh: Sometimes, when I
write something, it's, like,
"Is this right? Is this right?"
It makes me nervous about it.
It's good when she says,
"Don't worry about spelling."
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: The teacher is
both allowing these English learners
to feel that they can be
competent because they're writing
about themselves, which is
something they know well,
and she's also reducing their anxiety
and their fearfulness about the use
of the language by putting grading
aside and really enabling them
to just become fluent before they
learn all of the conventions.
>>Kirsten: At the end of the unit, I
need to see the entire writing process.
We're going to be handing it back and
forth as you continue to make progress
in your academic writing until
we're ready to make it into poetry.
>>Kirsten: In the practice
and in the problem solving
and in the troubleshooting,
they get a chance to look
at where their work didn't go well
or where they didn't meet the target.
Then they get to rework
it and revise it.
>>Masoumeh: She says, "I love your
mistakes. It's okay to make mistakes.
By mistake, you can learn more."
She's a good teacher.
>>Dr Cantor: This teacher wants
children to embrace the process
of figuring something out and
making it better, and to enjoy that.
So these kids, had they been
graded early, it would've shut
down that effort instead
of opening it up.